I've just read the paper which answers
the question why is mercury a liquid
motor is special because it's the only
metal that's unarguably a liquid gallium
you can melt when you warm it in your
hands but mercury is the only metal
that's liquid at room temperature it's
even liquid if you stick it in snow so
it's really no argument there's
something special about it
yes chemists and physicists have known
for a long time it's a liquid because
the forces between the atoms are weaker
than they are say with gold or other
elements but nobody has been able to do
calculations to show why the melting
point to mercury is minus 39 degrees
centigrade but they have now and it
turns out that the key to all of this is
relativity in fact the article I've read
has a special picture on the front of
the journal cover which shows a picture
of Einstein when he had had that looked
like mine so it's really does connect
relativity with mercury now the
important aspect of relativity that's
involved is the fact that relativity
says that if you take an object and
accelerate it to a very high speed close
to the speed of light or a good fraction
of it it becomes heavier how does this
apply to natum well atom has a
positively charged nucleus and a
negatively charged electron going round
and round so for a light a term like
hydrogen which has just a single
positive charge the electron goes round
relatively slowly but as you get down
the periodic table and get bigger and
bigger atoms pretend this is mercury
with a big nucleus the inner electrons
have to go round at terrific speed or
else they would tumble into the nucleus
and in fact that speed becomes a
significant fraction of the speed of
light so the electrons become heavier
and sink towards the nucleus so heavier
atoms are actually smaller than you
might expect because of these
relativistic effects and you can do
calculations to show that this has a
genuine effect for example the go
the color of the metal gold is due to
relativistic effects of the electrons in
the case of mercury what this paper has
shown and it has quite a nice title
evidence for low temperature melting of
mercury owing to relativity it's quite a
simple title and a very bold statement
what they have shown is that you can
explain the weak interactions between
mercury atoms in terms of this
relativistic effect now it's quite
complicated in general the forces
between atoms are determined by their
size and by their electron distribution
how the electrons are arranged and the
smaller the atom and the more tightly
the electrons are held so the weaker the
forces now what this paper says which is
very interesting is that if you take two
mercury atoms isolated imagine in the
gas phase the forces between them don't
change very much with if you include
relativistic effects in the calculations
or not but it is only when you think of
a whole group of mercury atoms as you
would imagine in a small droplet or
micro nano droplet that the relativistic
effects become important and this work
has taken a long time to do because you
need a really big computer to be able to
handle the calculations when you have a
large group of atoms and you're doing
the calculation about all those atoms at
the same time in these calculations they
have looked at the effect of putting a
relativistic correction because you can
do the calculation with an atom without
taking a relativity in the count or with
relativity in the count and so they've
done this for two atoms and then they've
done for lots and lots and lots which
simulates the
and in particular they can calculate the
melting point that is when a solid metal
turns into liquid and they've shown that
without relativistic effects they
calculate a melting point of 82 degrees
centigrade which is only a little bit
less than the melting point of sodium
and higher than the melting point of
cesium but with the relativistic effect
the melting point drops to the close to
the observed melting point of 39 degrees
so they can actually calculate a number
which is very close to the melting point
of mercury what they are showing is that
when you put in the relativistic effect
and effectively contract the inner
electrons of the motor atoms this has
enough effect on the outer electrons of
the atoms to stop the forces that would
make it into a solid you can see even
without the relativistic effects mercury
wouldn't have a very strong interaction
between the atoms it would melt at 82
degrees centigrade rather than the
thousands of degrees that you find on
some of the other elements but this is
if you like the fine tuning the
relativity that takes the melting point
from a boring above room temperature to
a really exciting below room temperature
so the fact that mercury is a liquid is
more proof that Einstein was right yes
of course the next challenge is to do
the same calculation with copernicium
element 112 because it's in the same
room as mercury and as you know that
elements in the same group in the
periodic table have similar properties
so copernicium could have an even lower
melting point so we look forward to the
paper on the melting point of copán it's
Ian
and so this actually led people to
suggest that there might actually be
another planet that was perturbing the
orbit of mercury that was even closer to
the Sun so people came up with the idea
that there was this planet called Vulcan
even closer to the Sun that was actually
causing it